planning a vacation is tricky business
in these socially distant times but a
small
italian community claims it has all the
right ingredients for a getaway during
the pandemic
it's even banking that just the right
number of tourists can help make it
become
a household name but it's the price that
may be the biggest selling point and our
chris livesay
shows us all about it
good morning now when you think of the
italian countryside tuscany often comes
to mind and if you want roman ruins well
go to pompeii
but there's one tiny italian region that
has both of those things
and more plus a new deal that's
irresistible
for tourists southern towns have a
reputation for hospitality
but perhaps none deserve it more than
san giovanni in galdo
the remote italian village population
500
is rewarding these tourists with free
lodging just
for coming here the idea to put the
village and the entire region
on the tourist map it's a a wonderful
a gorgeous surprise adriano rosso and
fulvia mignone
arrived a few days ago to a hero's
welcome what was your first
impression it was amazing
we said all these things is for us
before coming they applied online rosso
was looking for inspiration for his
paintings which he donated to the town
so it may not have the stunning canals
of venice or the breathtaking
renaissance art of florence
but what it does have is genuine italian
life
virtually all to yourself
not to mention rustic food you won't
find on tourist routes
so i'm about to eat a local delicacy
that is
stuffed sheep intestines it would be
rude
not to but also handmade pasta and sauce
with fresh
local ingredients common in the
surrounding molise region
so small and out of the way even
italians joke it doesn't really exist
molise more like malicent that's despite
boasting roman amphitheaters and ruins
not to mention wide open spaces ideal
for social distancing
molise has had one of the lowest rates
of covet 19
in the country that's partly because
village populations have been declining
for decades
do people live in all of these homes as
locals sell or abandon their homes to
seek jobs in cities like rome and milan
says mayor domenico credico the tourists
who come here stay in apartments
restored by the town
luring them here with free vacations has
been a spectacular success for such a
tiny hamlet
so 8 000 people requested to come here
but mass tourism isn't what they're
after he says
in the age of covet 19 a lack of crowds
is its own
attraction as are the friendships that
can only be formed on an
intimate scale the main reason this
couple says
they can't wait to come back one
very important thing in melisa
that you can't
every day find in other regions
these people people here is really
special real wonderful
now of course getting here is still a
challenge with that eu
travel ban still in place on americans
fortunately
the town says as soon as it's lifted
americans are
more than welcome to have their free
vacation here too
for cbs this morning saturday chris
livesay molise
italy sign me i think we're all in
anywhere in italy as soon as possible
would be wonderful with sheep intestines
maybe maybe not how's your stomach doing
it's better good
all right there's your update from
michelle